thank you
[Music]
in November of 2021 the cryptocurrency
space wasn't full Madness I remember I
called peaky for you
call it cryptomania Nickel Mania retail
investors Millennials gen Z everyone's
getting in driven by fomo and nobody
wants to miss out right one of the
biggest
um procurers of crypto
Mark Zuckerberg even changed his name as
a [ __ ] company to meta as as in
metaverse because the craze had just
gotten so wild but he's like you know
what I'll be first right I'm gonna
change my company the metaverse and
that's where we're going we're gonna put
10 billion dollars towards building the
metaverse whatever the [ __ ] that means
okay well Mark Cuban was out in the
Forefront saying crypto is part of the
future crypto is inevitable and now he
is saying crypto is missing something
what is it missing crutches or something
when you got to get Luka doncic involved
if he was involved in the NC space it
wouldn't have crashed you think Mark
came in are you no Luca Dunkin yeah
rookie card is like what two million
dude no way wasn't he a rookie just five
years ago or some [ __ ] the basketball
card game is not what it was like when
we were but what it was different now
what do you mean like it's worth more
now so like there should be container
that burst open yeah the way the way the
cards work now like basketball cards are
like of these Superstars like the ones
that are like quote unquote guaranteed
to be superstars
like I don't know how long ago maybe 10
15 years ago people just started buying
ridiculous prices they started paying
like a thousand dollars for a car and
they just elevated and now like started
like Don chips dude a million 1.5 to 2
million whoa what about old school cars
like Gary Payton or some [ __ ] because
Gary's an older star the only ones from
old old that work really well is Michael
Jordan no Babe Ruth Kobe Bryant signed
cards because he can't sign anymore
they're super they're even more limited
now uh Tom Brady so like it's got to be
like a superstar from back then because
I got a ton of cars from back then not
to brag but I have the first ever issued
Tom Brady NFC do you really I do do you
know how much it's worth now
not much
did it come out of a dragon egg I knew
as much as that okay so so Mark so
that's that is interesting though oh the
basketball card game is it's crazy are
you into it I'm like I dip my toe in it
yeah um and so I have a couple cards uh
I won't say which ones yeah but like I I
dip my tones there's some real shitty
ones I heard what does it rhyme with
yeah I heard you have some really shitty
marked up Scotty Pippins
it's got teeth marks on there I heard it
cost more money just to ship them out of
your house yeah it costs a lot of money
to get them graded that's that's what I
don't like the whole thing the rating
thing is subjective and so a lot of it
is I've heard you've got to be friendly
with them it's political yeah so like it
like 10 is the highest right so if you
get a nine it's really good but like
what the difference between an eight
nine ten this is not much it's just does
the guy like you know that's a
subjective
like yeah did they get a [ __ ] last
night and maybe they woke up be like
Life's good I oh this card's really
awesome how do you be nice to somebody
that you're shipping it you know they
come so there's you ship this takes a
long time or sometimes they make
appearances yeah they'll go to like
they'll go to Convention and you just
take everything and so like are you the
first card they saw or are you the
thousands before they saw that hour you
know comic books is the same [ __ ] right
there's a company called cgc which is
like the most used one and if you have
like a nine eight of like one of the
classics you're [ __ ] set a 9 8 is
considered like near mint like perfect
condition basically because there's no
[ __ ] 10 right there's no semen stuck
between yeah but like if you have a
cgc98 it's like a whole [ __ ] industry
out there so like people there's a lot
of like shade in the comic World about
that and how they determine that and
same kind of [ __ ] same ideas Tom Fuller
human base like there's [ __ ] human
beings behind it so there's room for
corruption but Mark Cuban is saying
crypto still has a place but it's
missing something what's missing to him
is new applications he feels like
there's not enough things going on
application wise that justifies a lot of
these crypto projects existences which I
think is pretty fair yeah that's fair
yeah um he said he finds the space
boring utilization like being able to
like transact with it like
Luna was pretty funny because we all
thought there'd be a lot by now real
world applications how many are there
through crypto it's pretty limited right
like it like it's still beta especially
post crash exactly it's technically zero
right
no there's maybe the El Salvador or
whatever but they they could buy stuff
through bit but even then it's not that
it's not that no because if you actually
think about lightning Network lightning
network has some real world implications
that you can use right now for like a
normie yeah yeah yeah for payments but
but it's just about getting adoption
adoption is lacking too because that's
what I think when like things actually
pop off isn't just a regular like like
my dad is gonna is using ethereum or
Bitcoin somehow you know right but until
it gets there then it's still like in
development what's your take on the
crypto space Walter
I think the application is huge because
I don't have never used it yeah I've
never used it for anything I I've I've
only hoped that people use it so that
the value of it goes up dude I've booked
plane tickets bought things online like
yeah and there's like what there's like
wallets that we can just send share
whatever the cross train multi-chain and
yeah and there's different
I guess like apps and and and and
networks that are trying and I think
like you got to kind of be a nerd in the
space yeah you have to really it blows
people's mind that they're like wait you
can use Bitcoin to buy things now but
but but the thing is
five four years ago whatever right I was
in France and they were already using
accepting Bitcoin in their registers for
sure that's the thing that was like when
you're saying you have to kind of Be A
Nerd to follow Mo the average person is
not going to be a nerd about it no and
so my thing is is like I've only hoped
that it gets to a point where everyone
uses it just so that I don't end up in
the minus yeah because you know my
money's still in I haven't sold it's
just still in there you know I'm sure
safe moon is now worth Point like 12
zeros and one you know now but like I I
hope at one point but I don't know if
it'll happen it just it depends who
people are listening to if they're
listening to conservative people they're
not gonna do they're not gonna do any
coin if they're listening to people that
are more Progressive and aggressive
they're like okay let's do this but just
I'm always in the hope of that they do
but personally for me like I know a
friend because of Dogecoin got a car
um I've got nothing from Dogecoin I'm
minus in Dojo yeah so it's I don't know
but yeah for me like I don't follow
crypto enough to like speak
intelligently about it but mine's more
just a hope yeah same like like hey you
guys yeah dude
keep putting money in yeah yeah
dude
so I can get out
it's like a rug cool totally like Tesla
dude like keep putting money into it so
I can get out yeah I won't get the [ __ ]
out yeah honestly like when you talk
when you talk to conservative people not
like um politically but like um
financially yeah like Risk adverse
people yeah yeah risk adverse that's way
better way more accurate like the way
they talk about stocks it's like oh no
why why would you even do that like like
t-bills are like sound risky to them and
then but I think like you know but
that's such a nice
like like unstressful way of like living
your life
but it's so boring it's boring even even
with as much as I've gotten killed in
crypto lately I'm still beating me and
Nikki's 401K that's wild so it's like
okay there's still enough like to be
gained in crypto especially if you're
paying attention to space like I I'm
pretty uh heavily into the space I love
the space still nothing that happened to
Luna detracted from My Love of the space
it's just like another day in the office
for me but I get people who are just
like [ __ ] man like I think I can't
handle that [ __ ] it's a mental thing
like what happened to you in Tesla it
just depends on if you can handle it or
not what like sure bro I never put that
much into crypto so losing what I lost
which is [ __ ] crazy it wasn't that
crazy to me because I'm like well I I
never put that much in so it just
doesn't [ __ ] with my head as much but I
and I love what it could maybe do yeah
for us all one day for me the big
difference between stocks and crypto is
stocks is from 6 30 in the morning to 1
pm
crypto's 24 hours well now if you're on
Solana oh well I couldn't keep up Solana
um the blockchain gets halted all the
time oh that's okay that's nice yeah
that's really nice because when I was
doing crypto
it was 24 hours
at four in the morning I'm like yeah
what's going on you're not gonna have
that problem Solana it's basically a
nine to five blockchain and they're like
hey sorry you can't use a lot right now
because like we were we have some kind
of bug but it'll be fine we're on
vacation I'm sorry price goes up three
percent of the next day so it's like hey
good at least Corporate America has our
backs
so that's tight yeah I'm saying yeah
yeah pretty much I was doing what was uh
I forgot what it was called it started
with a but it would it was time to go up
10 down percent 10 up 10 is it Avalanche
it wasn't a badge
cardano Ada but that sounds more fun Ada
yeah but like um you know you buy
obviously by low so high and stuff and I
would do that but because it's 24 hours
like I'm like oh I keep looking at it
I'm like okay you gotta stop looking at
Michael but I can't because what if it's
on the down and then I have to sell I'm
like ah it was just it was just too much
like stocks I like that it's 6 30 to 1.
even though right now I'm not really
paying attention to the market because
I'm getting killed okay
I really don't like looking at it I
think it's more of a psychological thing
because in investing in just risk
anything that involves risk you just
gotta have the mind and perspective for
it because it's the same thing in stocks
too even if it shuts down at six or like
whatever yeah I think like
you're really going in and at that point
to me the way I see investing right is
like once it's released into that
atmosphere
then it's game on and I can't view it
the same way as it was in my bank
account so like when it's in my bank
account like the fluctuates or like to
me it's like
the actual that's why they say it's
realized gains and losses right because
like if it's just like in the game going
up and down you haven't really lost or
you haven't really gained because you
haven't cashed out the real game happens
or the end game happens when you make
your decision to sell or or whatever
right so that's kind of my psychology
behind it where it's like I can sit here
and say yeah I lost over a million
dollars whatever whatever but did I
really because those are paper gains and
losses my real losses in principle and
that's always been my philosophy so like
that is the scary part though because
then for me it feels like
okay here's my son be very very careful
with my son and then they put my son on
a roller coaster
and he didn't realize gains or losses
and you just see your money going whoa
and then you get it back you're like oh
my God okay it's safe oh thank God what
we're trying to say is that he can
afford to lose his son yeah
that makes sense to me because you can
afford to lose yourself yeah that's the
part that's okay we're just down one son
and you see the whole Market go like
crazy with your baby yeah you're like oh
[ __ ] that's why you got to put your kids
you don't care about on that right
that's why you have 10 kids and then you
throw one in there and you go are you
having fun all right all right well you
don't put kids on there and you barely
put Park admission in there and then
people and then people see you run up to
a million and they call you a loser for
because you got wrecked on it but even
though you're still up but it's like
you're still a loser I guess you know
that's and that's a mentality shift too
is that you're you're you're up but then
you're you're down and so I was like oh
you lost so much money yeah but I'm
still I started with 20 bucks damn right
you know and so there's things like that
that's my game baby and by the way I
have been crushing this bear Market no
joke I have been crushing this bear
Market you look like it dude I know I
feel like dress I can tell by your
crushed uh velvet soup thank you
yeah I'm not gonna lie to you I've been
secretly touching it without you knowing
[Music]
foreign